Wow, Chris, that's a really tough order of operations problem. But, if you got
the answer of negative 88, great job. The first thing that we want to do when we
look at an order of operation problem is to do the innermost parentheses first.
I can see right here, there is the innermost parentheses of 6 minus 6 squared.
So the first thing I'm going to do is calculate 6 minus 6 squared. 6 squared is
36, so I have 6 minus 36. And of course, 6 minus 36 gives me a negative 30. It's
important when doing these order of operation problems that you write down all
of the operations that you have not yet performed. So I'm going to copy down the
rest of the problem. So for this first step, I simply evaluated what was in the
innermost parentheses, which 6 minus 36 is negative 30. Now I'm working in the
brackets and I know that I have to do my powers or my exponents first. So
negative 5 squared is negative 25 and 6 squared is 36. Now that I've evaluated
all my exponents or powers, the next thing I want to do is my multiplication.
When I do my multiplication, it's a good idea to work from the left to the
right. I'm still working in these brackets. So, the two multiplications that I
have to do are negative 25 times negative 2, which gives me positive 50. I leave
the minus 36 and the other multiplication that I have to do is negative 1 times
negative 30 which gives me positive 30. Now that I have finished all the
exponents, multiplication, and division within my brackets, now I can do my
addition and my subtraction. 50 minus 36 is 14, and then, I can add the 14 and
the 30. 14 plus 30 gives me 44. The last thing I need to do is this last
operation, which is multiplication. Negative two times 44 gives me negative 88.